tan
[音楽]
ああああああ
リア上の機能したと申します a
私の方からは越冬まあ森林っていうのがですねまぁどういう形で環境問題とか変わって
この8イベントが環境問題に対してどのように具体的なアクションを起こすかっていう
ことで
えっというテーマだとを起動しますので私たちとしてはその森林を
に関わることによってそういったさまざまな課題を課題の解決につながるのではないか
ということで
ええとあなたのその関わり方について a
提案をさせていただきたいというふうに思います
8私はの林野庁というところでへと日本の森林を扱っている役所ですえっと今までは
新緑を造成するということが基本的な子だったんですけれども
これをですね具体的にどどのような形で8私たちの生活に彼からしていくかって事を
えっと私の8 c 今の仕事をテーマとしては行っています
えーとこれはへと10月26日に出した8菅総理の江藤
所信表明演説の中の言葉ですけれども
まあえっとグリーン社会の実現ということで再生可能エネルギーとかそれからまあ環境
分野のデジタル化
まあこういうことを行うことによって
グリーン社会社会の8砕石をしていくということが8初診の表面の中で語られました
その中でまあそれを通じてへと成長戦略を持っていくんだということでこれに必要に
なるのは革新的なイノベーションが必要だということでまぁこういった
の内容だったかと思います
でえっとこれと前後してですね8まあ環境に大きく関わると環境省と農林水産省の方で
連携の強化ということでエペソの協定を結びました
この中でへと掲げられているのはまずあの立山所堺のまあ実現
まあこのために惑い風な形で
先ほど行ったえっイノベーションどういうふうに交通つっ使っていくのか
それから循環経済を高圧作っていこう
それともう一つ書かれているのは分散型社会ということでまぁ1人が8項集まること
3つになることによって様々な社会の弊害がを告発してきていると
まあこれを分散型社会によって実現して以降これが
とグリーン社会であり a 棟
まあリリーデザインをしていこうということが
この中で歌われていますでこれにおいて必要なことはまあ先ほど行った革新的なにゴム
で書の保管にですね
この社会だとか人々の行動変容まあこういったことが8必要なのではないかということ
でこの具体の行動編をどうしていくかということが
は8大きなテーマの1つ気になっている
ているかというふうに思います
さてその真偽というのはまあ具体にどういうふうにこの a
環境問題と関わっているかということで大きなテーマがどこの a
いわゆるその
炭素の削減目標との中根新銀河どういうふうに位置付けられているかということです
a
今のえっと京都議定書でその1森林の吸収量というのが算定のカウントされる形になり
ましてこれがまあ今のパリ協定まで
まあ8こういう位置づけがされているという形になります
この吸収量の目標の中でですねドッグ300可能になるのは1990年から比較をして
新規にショクリを植えたというところのこの左の
森林それから右側の人々じんじん医によってきちんと適切な管理された森林というのが
この算定の対象になりますという形になります
で a
まぁ日本の場合はですねまぁ90年時短時点では方法
国土の多くは森林になってますから以下にこの適切な森林管理をしていくかという
ところが
まあこの吸収量の算定上も大きなテーマになってきます
干ばつなどで人が手を入れた森林地では適切に
まあ関与していく森林を整備をしていくということが
まあ吸収量場も非常にも
重要なテーマになっています
でただその森林はその環境問題という意味でも考えても九州の話だけではなくてへと
非常に多面的な機能を有していますここに掲げられているのは8まあ主な機能の項目
ですけども
例えば国土を保全する土砂災害を防止をしたりだとか
それから水源を関与したりそれから保険だとかレクリエーションとしての利用だとか
もちろん木材を使う木材生産それから昨日来たも生産とか
それから地球環境問題もそうですしあとは生物多様性の保全と
ヒューマー様々な機能があります
この機能はある機能だけを高めようとするとほかの機能はやっぱり失われているきて
しまうという
付
いわゆる逆の側面もあります例えば吸収量を増やそうと思えば水曜いっぱい増えれば
いいということですけれどもそれはて対応生物多様性の保全は守れないとか
水源涵養の問題も出てきますなのでこういった信玄の機能を発揮させるには様々な森林
を
たようで健全な森林におこう
に誘導していくとまあこういったことが非常に重要になってきます
バランスで多様な健全
作用で健全な森林あるこういった心理をつくっていくということが重要なのでそのため
多様な面
多様な機能11側面ではなくでいろんな面を見ながら森林と関わっていくということが
この森林とかかることで非常に重要になります
じゃあこれまでどうやっどのようにですね1人々が新銀とか変わってきたかということ
で
と過去の日本のまあこれまでもですね関わり方っていうのを少しご紹介をしていきたい
とおもいます
これは左の方はですねこれはへと東海道五十三次の箱根の絵ですけれども
山を見るとほとんどハゲ天っていうかです松が越冬つ
ポロポロと生えているとまぁこんな状態です松は先駆的な樹種ですのであれた森林に
入り最初に入る山で右の比叡山だとかということを書いて
ますけれどもこの昭和初期の山ですけどここだけじゃなくて日本中
森林はこういう状態でした
それを8私たちの先人たちが努力によってみたいしたのように a とっ
緑に緑を豊かな国土に帰ってきたと非常に石
時昔はですね人と新銀河近くてそれが出て人と関わりながら今の森林ができてきたと
いうことがこの下からもわかると思います
でわが国はえっと言われてるえっと国土面積の7割が森林ですけれども
先進国でも非常に多い森林率になっていますけれども今の心理の状態は
先人たちが守りと関わってきたからこその結果であると
しかしまぁ今こういうの中になって非常に守りと関わることが少なくなってきてるん
じゃないかというふうに思います
皆さんはですねあの最近森林に関わったということは8先にどれぐらいあるでしょうか
ほとんど多分皆さんあまりこう最近守りに入っていったっていう強化そんなに置いて
あるよっていう人が少ないかと思います
森林とかカールってことはまあ様々な8面で関わることができるってことで
えーと今 sdg ずの観点からですのもう非常に呻吟と関わることがさまざまな s
字地蔵の目標に関係していくっていうことを
この絵で表していますもちろん持続可能な森林経営をすることによって先ほどの
ようないろんな機能を発揮させるということはともかく
a
切ったら植えてさらに育ててまた使っていくということをこういったバランスを取れた
新銀の状態を
と関わることによって様々なえっと
目標を達成することができるかと思います森との関わりが希薄化した今日はこういった
目線でやはり8森林との
関係構築っていうのを行っていく必要があるのではないか
これがいろんなそういった8問題の解決だになっていくんじゃないかということで割っ
を提案したいと思います
でそこで提案するのが森と人と新たなかかわりということで
8私たちはフォレストスタイルということを言葉をつけさせてもらって提案をさせて
いただきたいと思いますこれまでは a 棟
まあ神左のほうですけども非常にまあコアな8
まあニーズの人だとかあるいは森林がだ
いい子だから木を植えていこうとかまあそういったことを非常に強そうだとか
非日常あるいは単発的なあーちんびんとの関わり方っていうのが今までの7人との
関わり方だと思うんですそれを様々な8場面で森林を使っていこうということで日常的
でしかも継続的でさらにいろんな人一般層も含めて
ですね色んなリヨン仕方をやっていこうってことがこのフォレスト左右の考え方です
両氏は買いだと牡蠣好きだとかそれからいろんな周辺のサービスを合わせていろんな
健康の場面それから企業活動もばべ
教育の場面様々な面々で森林と関わっていきましょう
森林を積極的に生活の中に取り入れることで健康で5
心豊かな
そういったライフスタイルをフォレストスタイルという風な形で体気を付けて
これを皆様にご提案をさせて頂ければと思います
こういった多様な関わり方を通じて賃金の理解先ほど行ったいろんな機能を持つ森林の
理解増進つながり
いろんな環境問題を考えるきっかけになるんじゃないかということで提案をさせて
いただきます
ていた
でフォレストスタイルは様々な行動名誉を行う
人生100年時代の中で様々な場面で心理とそれぞれ書かせていこうということで考え
ています
例えば教育の場面で自然保育みたいな話だとかそれから学校活動の中それから端具羽目
になるといろんな
越冬わぁ化粧の話それからメンタルヘルス後場でそれから企業の健康づくりの場でこう
いった利用
それから老年期になってもいろんな運動予防た運動とか介護予防の問題それから
いろんな
土台の人生の社会活動だとかあるいは日症予防みたい話こういったことで様々な場面で
森林と関わることが
できるかと思いますそれからダークてぃびてぃみたいなものも
今までえっ
そのまーたんある登山後ですねいやを高めることによっていろんな8 upty び
てぃに帰って行ったりだとか
グランピングみたいなこともたぶんそうだと思いますしそれから街の中でやってたこと
を開いた森の中であるようがだとかカフェだとか
まあこういったことも含めてですねさまざま森林と関わる
場面というのが考えられるかというふうに思います
でこれを進めるためにはまあいろんな
アクティビティーそれからいろんな楽しみ方それから周辺サービスも含めていろんな8
業界だとか人々思いを持った人人っていうのがこれがですねうまく工連携をして交流し
てさまざまな複合的な連携をさせながら
法との関わり方をつくっていくこれによって8総合サービスを作っていくってことが
取り組みが重要になってくるかと思います8リア上でも今こういった8交流をする
仕組みっていうのを今8
チェーンとしてますのでまだ越冬近々見合う様にいろんな形でご提案をさせて頂ければ
というふうな形で考えています
で1 a 森との関わり方という意味で何から関わっていいかどういうふうに効果
変わることができるのかってことで
a それがえっ
心理と遠ざけているひとつかと思います私たちとしてはいろんな場面で例えば
一番アクション市の方で働き方の部分でいろんな働く場面に森を取り入れていく
それからアクションにで気を使うことによって
て道ように気を使うことによって守りとか変わっていく
それからさーんの方は生活の中で
森を感じるいろんな仕組みを使うあるいはいろんな商品を使って守りとか変わっていく
それからいろいろな伝統的なものの裁量だとか
えーまぁそういったことにも関わっていくこういう関わり方もあるかと思いますそれ
からイノベーションによって新たな8も力を使い方
とか利用の仕方っていうのが生まれてきていますこういったことでそれぞれの場面で
様々
関わることが今できるような形で
なってきてますのでこれをみなさまにこんな関わり方ができるってことを
またご提案をさせていただきますというふうに思います
街の中には木材利用がいろんな場面で進んでます
え
役だとかそれから金融機関今いろんな建物の中でもそうですし
それから暮らしの中でも8おもちゃそれからいろんな体験だとか
それからね r マンみたいな香りの部分だとかいうことで様々な関わり方がええ
森林との関わり方がこういう形で出来るかというふうに思いますので
また8いろんな8ものを見つけてですねこんな関わり方を8
体感押して頂ければというふうに思います
今コロナかということで新しい
一条ニューノーマルの話が言われていますけれどももともと真理の道じゃなかった空間
です
ですのでまあ今のこういった新しい日常においてはこのえっと森林を使ってです
いろんな
後者が変革っていうのが可能になってくるかと思います
新技を持つようないろんな特製心が
安文安らぐだとかそれからやされる
まあいろんなその身体とか心に変えツルエビ論が特性も含めてですねそういった特性を
理解をして社会だとか人々の行動編をつながる
具体的な行動とか連携構築と様がいまし
ようになってきているのかなと思いますので一つ8皆さんの中でそうれた森林の関わり
方がどういうふうにあるのかということでまた私たちがだ末と情報も含めてですね
また考える機会を
いただければというふうに思います
私からは以上ですけれどもえ
今こういった世の中の中で森林と関わっていくということがええまあ環境問題もそう
ですし
いろんな社会課題
あるいはかでまあそういったことをですねあのうまー
私たち女性はそういった心理を使うことでいろんな課題解決つながるきっかけがこの中
に眠っているんじゃないかと思います
多様性だとかいうことを一番票納税してるのは森森林ってことだと思いますのでそこを
理解することによってさまざま
8私たちの車間書いていければというふうに思いますのでと皆さんまた
考える機会をいただければと思います a
ありがとうございました